necessarily reflective views and
opinions of 8 news now or nextar Media
Group
it said dead heat right now I mean it's
going to be a toss-up
tonight on politics now one on one with
the governor Steve sisolak outlines why
he says he deserves another four years
in office
they should have been paying their
employees the right way all along and
offering health insurance breaking down
the ballot questions a closer look at
what could change from the minimum wage
to how we vote
groups are continually trying to get
people to turn out a vote and one way is
to use social pressure you're probably
getting more mail than usual right now
but some people are questioning one
particular flyer you may have seen
Dayton is now investigators dig for
answers
[Music]
from 8 news now this is politics now
thank you for joining us here on
politics now I'm John langler we're a
little more than a week away from the
election and that races are really
heating up the race for governor is one
of several neck and neck contests right
now this week I sat down with Governor
Steve sisolak about his re-election
campaign
so let's just talk about the campaign
overall obviously the polls show that
it's it's neck and neck between you and
your opponent a lot of the races are
that way right now
um talk about where you think you are
your campaign is in the race to
re-election with just a couple of weeks
left well it's it's a dead heat right
now I mean it's going to be a toss-up
we're working hard got a tremendous
field operation going
hundreds if not thousands of volunteers
across the state are getting out there
knocking on doors making phone calls and
the biggest thing is going to be turn up
we got to get people turned out to vote
uh We've ided people and registered
people so now we've got to make sure
that they vote before election day
whether they vote by mail early voting
or in person they've got a lot of
options and in fact people that aren't
even registered we encourage them you
can show up to the polls until the polls
close on Election Day and still register
to vote you know I think a lot of
political scientists would say the
incumbent sort of has the inherent
Advantage when they're running for
reelection and yet you and a lot of the
polling it's either neck and neck or
you're a point down a point here and
there you know within the margin of
error why do you think you're struggling
to sort of maybe reconnect with Nevada
voters well I don't think it's a matter
of reconnecting I think my opponent is
funded by one individual that's given 25
million dollars to his campaign that's
unheard of Nevada politics for one
person to put 25 million dollars into a
race who didn't like the eviction
moratorium that we put in place and
that's unfortunate but we're confident
we can get our message out there we
can't compete with this 25 million
dollar donor but we've got a lot of
Grassroots support
you talk about money a lot of your ads
talk about how you want to do all of
these things and some things are already
in the works without raising taxes a lot
of that's from the the federal monies
getting over the pandemic if you're
re-elected how would a lot of those
programs those efforts that you're
pushing forward stay in existence
because at some point the money would
kind of run out no oh certainly the
federal money runs out a lot of the
federal money we put into one shot
things like affordable housing half a
billion dollars 500 million dollars that
won't be up you know we'll do what we
can we're looking at a budget surplus
coming up for the economic Forum before
the legislature starts our economy has
recovered faster than anybody anybody
anticipated I mean we're regained every
single job we lost before the pandemic
we've led the country for six months two
quarters in a row in terms of economic
recovery you've seen the win on the uh
in Nevada and the gaming win has been
over a billion dollars like 18 or 19
months in a row I mean we're breaking
records so it's bringing more money into
the state and we'll be able to utilize
some of that money to continue what
we've done and do some really good
things you know it's what a lot of
people say jobs are coming back and
unemployment is at such and such level
the dirty numbers below that is also
what are those jobs are they being paid
as much as they were before the pandemic
and are they making enough to to live
the cost of living is going up how would
you if we re-elected try and bridge that
gap of the rising cost of living in
southern Nevada and all across the state
yeah we've got to get better jobs
there's no doubt about that uh we've got
30 40 000 people here still out of work
and they've got a hundred thousand jobs
available the job skills just aren't
matching up with the jobs uh we need you
to do better job of getting people into
more skill jobs retraining I'll give you
an example uh we've got uh in the trades
The Building Trades the apprenticeship
programs we've got great job
opportunities that are available we just
don't have enough people that are
skilled whether it's in the carpentry
program the culinary program cosmetology
electricians welding whatever it might
be if you've got a CDL license right now
commercial driver's license you can
write your own ticket you know there's
such a demand for these operators so we
got to give our young people an
opportunity that when they're in high
school or middle school they're deciding
what they do every it shouldn't go to
college I mean they're coming out of
college unfortunately a lot of these
kids with a hundred thousand dollars
worth of student debt and can't find a
job and it's tough to pay that back so
if you get a new skilled trade you can
learn something you can find your way
out of college and I talk to some folks
at the uh the HVAC company up north
where they have an apprenticeship
program then sheet metal and it's a
five-year program their kids will earn
360
000 over five years and come up with no
debt there are ads that are out there
right now sort of blaming uh your
opponent the sheriff for some of the
rise in crime at the same token the uh
the sheriff will bring up the laws that
were passed up in Carson City and and
the the measures on crime that have led
to maybe they would suggest the lack of
enforcement or the ability to enforce
being hindered
is there a shared responsibility on the
rise in crime between the governor and
the sheriff of the biggest county in the
state well I think everybody's got some
responsibility but clearly I signed a
bill with the sheriff either supported
or was neutral on I made it clear to the
chairman of that committee and he's
written a letter that said to the fact
that I told him if the sheriff can't be
in agreement with this can't support it
I'm not going to sign the bill the
sheriff was okay with it now suddenly
when he can't control crime he's the one
who can't control crime we've got a
problem he's blaming me he is sitting on
125 million dollars in reserve funds 125
million dollars and hasn't had a police
academy to train any new officers we
need that money implemented we need that
money out on the street and officers are
patrolling our neighborhoods because
people aren't as safe as they were two
or four years ago prior to when he
became sheriff it's the more dangerous
Community it's because he's failed in
his responsibility as a sheriff but on
the same token if you look at state law
enforcement you talk to people from
Nevada State Police we just saw what
happened with the escaped convicted
murderer from the conviction the
correction center in southern Nevada
that's a state office obviously that's
not the Clark County sure so that's your
responsibility isn't it absolutely and
the problem we have at the state level
our wages are held in based by uh
legislative function they set the red
the salaries that we have we train
people and the sheriff and the police
departments hire them away from us
because they can get a 30 raise as soon
as they leave say please so we become a
training ground for these other agencies
I have committed to doing a salary
adjustment for state police officers at
the beginning of next session to bring
them up to par with their sister
agencies so that we won't be losing all
the people we won't be hemorrhaging this
big group of officers who do a great job
to these private agencies yes I'm
responsible for the state function of
that and the inmate that escaped was
responsibility of parole you know our
state prison issue but the crime that
you're seeing your neighborhoods
homicides are up car thefts or thefts
are up rapes and robberies are up that's
the kind of thing that's responsibility
to sheriff this is his jurisdiction I
spent 10 years on the Clark County
Commission I was on fiscal Affairs for
those 10 years I know we had an officer
ratio of 2.0 which is what they'd
recommended at the national average he's
fallen way below that never gotten back
up there because I don't think he had
the skill to run the department at the
beginning and hasn't put those resources
into hiring officers you don't need the
rise in crime just last question on this
you don't think the rise in crime is
part of an more of a nationwide thing
it's not just Las Vegas it's seeing this
it's not just Clark County no it's not
just Clark County but if you look at the
17 counties in the state lot Clark
County is the highest I mean you can
deny it I mean Las Vegas is driving up
the crime rate statistics for the entire
State because it's so high in this one
County that that's bringing up the whole
state average we are I think less
statistic I saw I think we're on group
sixth or seventh in terms of murders per
100 000 people that's a Las Vegas
problem that's a Clark County Sheriff
problem final question here we just kind
of started with this it's crunch time
obviously the the midterms are just a
couple of weeks away
how do you convince voters you deserve
four more years by talking to them
talking about the good things that we've
done and what our plans are we can't
control inflation at the state level I
can't control the price of gasoline or
the price of a dozen eggs or a pound of
ground beef or chicken that's not
something a governor can do but we can't
help in other areas we get free school
lunches to every student in the state of
Nevada breakfast and lunch and my
opponent called that campaign gimmick we
provided 500 million dollars for
affordable housing in the state of
Nevada we've put money into child care
to make child care more affordable put
five million dollars into free community
college for people we're doing what we
can on the state Ed in order to save
people money uh prescription Rx card
they can save up to 80 on prescription
drugs so we're doing what we can on the
state end in order to get money back in
people's pockets
of course we have also invited
Republican gubernatorial candidate and
sheriff in Clark County Joe Lombardo to
appear here as well so far we have not
heard back you can find the full
interview with governor sisalak on
8newsnow.com there are also three ballot
initiatives this year on your midterm
ballot one of the most contentious is
question three it would create open
primaries and ranked Choice voting in
our elections here's a brief explainer
of how it would work
first it creates an Open Primary meaning
you can vote for anyone on the ticket
right now you can only vote for
Republicans if you're Republican Or
democrats if you're a Democrat
the top five would then go on to the
general election in the general election
you would rank them one through five if
someone gets more than 50 percent in the
general election they win if no one gets
fifty percent it goes to an instant
runoff the candidate with the fewest
votes gets eliminated their second
choice gets their votes and that
continues until someone has 50 percent
there's also question two which aims to
simplify our minimum wage Nevada's
minimum wage is already going up a bit
every year but as we found out
supporters of the measure well they want
it to go up the same for everyone
back in 2019 Nevada lawmakers agreed the
state's minimum wage should go up
assembly Bill 456 created a 75 cent
increase every year until 2024. in July
it went up to 10.50 an hour or 9.50 an
hour that discrepancy is based on
whether an employer offers health
insurance and supporters of question 2
want it gone they should have been
paying their employees the right way all
along and offering health insurance
Annette Magnus is with battleborn
progress she says question 2 makes
minimum wage fair if approved instead of
two different increases everything stays
the same that's just what employers are
going to have to do they're going to
have to pay a living wage to contr to
continue to attract good employees Magna
says many employers are simply offering
bad health insurance that way they can
pay workers a dollar an hour less she
believes with the Affordable Care Act
companies can take advantage anymore
there is no reason that a business in
2022 should not not be able to pay the
minimum wage the current format We
Believe works for now employers and
employees Paul Murad Khan is with the
Vegas chamber this is redundant and not
necessary to amend the state
constitution while we're already seeing
that's the current state law he points
out Nevada's average hourly wage is
already 28 dollars an hour instead he
believes money should go towards job
training programs market demand will
drive the salaries especially for
qualified workers and I think that the
bigger issue for the chamber in this
conversation is that we're focusing on
the wrong solution for the problem this
measure already passed in the state
legislature twice putting it on the
ballot this year if approved it would
create one 12 an hour minimum wage by
2024.
again the ballot would uh the measure
would adjust the minimum wage annually
for inflation after 2024 and if it
passes this time it would go into the
state constitution all right well early
voting is of course already underway
here in Nevada as of Thursday morning
more than 50 000 people have cast a
ballot here in Clark County that's much
lower than the early voting turnout back
in 2018. it averaged more than the than
26 000 votes cast every day that again
back in 2018.
Nye County officials will allow the
public to view hand counting of mail-in
ballots they'll be one of the first in
the country to let you watch hand
counting however if you're going to do
this observers have to sign a form first
agreeing not to release any information
before election day there is still a
legal Challenge from the ACLU on this at
the Nevada Supreme Court
if you need help getting registered to
vote we have you covered there's a guide
to help you with registration early
voting sites and information on how to
vote by mail you can find that at
8newsnow.com
cannabis is no longer regulated as a
classified substance in Nevada that
means research efforts can proceed
easier the eighth Judicial District
Court made that ruling this week
previously the State Board of Pharmacy
listed cannabis as a schedule one drug
that's defined as having no accepted
medical use and a high potential for
abuse but medical researchers have
argued that classification hinders
research for cannabis and marijuana
products
next year on politics now differing
stances on Public Safety Nevada's
attorney general and the woman running
to take his position share their views
on Criminal Justice Reform plus the 8
news now investigators look into a
curious election mailer you may have
gotten is it
for you is what I'll do
welcome back to politics now
[Music]
just like the governor's race Nevada's
race for Senate is very very close and
as you see here this week Donald Trump
Jr hosted a rally in Henderson this was
Tuesday night for Republican Senate
Challenger Adam lack salt also on
Tuesday incumbent Democratic senator
Catherine Cortez masto joined first time
and no American voters over at East Las
Vegas Library these pictures coming from
the Cortez masto campaign after voting
the group went to a latino-owned
restaurant to discuss the pandemic
survival
another contentious race in Nevada it is
the one for attorney general this week
we heard from Republican candidate
Seagal Chatta one topic she is focused
on is changing Criminal Justice Reform a
bill that was passed here in Nevada back
in 2019.
it increased habitual centers the
definition of a habitual offender from a
two-time felon to a five-time tough
felon I find that very disturbing okay
our streets are obviously now being
flooded with habitual offenders
Chatta says if she is elected she'll
reverse the changes made from that
measure last week we also heard from
current attorney general Aaron Ford and
he defended the Bill's Passage
we got everyone in the room at the exact
same time law enforcement with the ACLU
public defenders with the District
Attorney's You Name It We were in there
working and we were able to craft bills
that passed unanimously every Republican
in the assembly every Democrat every
Republican in the Senate and Democrat
and the governor signed it and that's
how you enhance Public Safety
Nevada has one of the most many of the
most watched races in the country right
now and one National Group is trying to
get Democrats to the polls but with a
questionable strategy eight news now
investigator Vanessa Murphy reports
some nevadans are receiving this mailer
about the November 8th election stating
who you vote for is private but whether
you vote is a matter of public record we
will be reviewing public records after
the election to determine whether or not
you joined your neighbors in voting
that's actually a tactic that's been
used by groups to try to actually
encourage people to vote Danley is an
associate professor of political science
at UNLV he points to research showing
this strategy Works a 2008 Yale study
concluded social pressure increases
voter turnout as we know that a lot of
people don't vote especially in midterm
elections they don't think the vote
counts that it matters so groups are
continually trying to get people to turn
out and vote and one way is to use
social pressure
could it work the opposite though of
rubbing a voter the wrong way yeah so
this particular flyer it does seem a
little aggressive and that's similar to
what the Nevada Secretary of State's
office is saying when we reached out
about the mailer a spokesperson wrote in
an email while it seems aggressive it
does not appear to meet the threshold
for voter intimidation so who's behind
it America votes a left-leaning
Washington dc-based political action
committee there is a local division
which in this 2022 overview released
Tuesday States it's working to re-elect
Catherine Cortez masto for Senate Steve
sisilak for governor and the Slate of
progressive candidates up and down the
ballot I think voter turnout is
especially an important for Democrats in
Nevada this year because you know
Biden's approval ratings are low so
Republicans have a lot of motivation to
turn out to the polls not so much for
the case for Democrats that's kind of a
concern for Democrat campaigns just
trying to get the turnout try to get
their supporters to turn out and vote we
reached out to America votes and a
spokesperson wrote in part there is a
lot at stake in this election and we
encourage everyone to make their voice
heard we requested an interview and
additional information for example how
many of these ballots were sent to
nevadans we haven't received a response
yet Vanessa Murphy 8 News Now
next on politics now helping Americans
save money we'll talk about some changes
announced by the bind Administration to
eliminate something that we all deal
with plus a closer look at other tight
political races across the country on
politics
[Music]
you're watching politics now
the White House is looking to save you
some money by eliminating what it's
calling junk fees the Biden
Administration says corporations are
raking in hundreds of billions of
dollars a year from hidden add-ons and
extra fees that would come from
something like an airline seat cable
bills concert tickets so new guidelines
being proposed will make certain
practices illegal
they're unfair in the marginalized
Americans the hardest especially
low-income folks and people of color
they Benefit Big corporations not
consumers not working families
and that changes now the administration
is also pushing companies to show the
full cost of a ticket up front that way
you're not surprised by a different cost
when you check out
we're also keeping an eye on early
voting elsewhere there are several key
races with the balance of power in
Washington D.C very much up in the air
Natalie brand reports
for the second time this month another
woman is accusing Georgia Senate
candidate Herschel Walker of paying for
her abortion going by Jane Doe she spoke
to reporters over a zoom call he
encouraged me to have an abortion
and gave me the money to do so the new
allegation comes as more than one
million Georgians have already voted in
the key contest between Walker and
Democratic incumbent Rafael warna I am a
registered independent and I voted for
Donald Trump in both elections the the
accuser who came forward Wednesday
called Walker a hypocrite for his
anti-abortion stance she says she had a
six-year relationship with Walker while
he was still married and playing in the
NFL her lawyer Gloria Allred shared what
she claimed was evidence including cards
a photo and this recording I want to say
I love you and I was thinking about you
Walker has denied the allegations I've
already told people this is a lie and
I'm not going to entertain Georgia is
one of five toss-up states that will
determine which party controls the U.S
Senate another is Pennsylvania where
voters saw the only debate between
Democrat John Federman and Republican
Amendment Oz on Tuesday fetterman who
suffered a stroke in May appeared to
struggle to communicate at times and my
doctors the real doctors that I believe
in they all believe that I'm ready to be
served but his supporters are apparently
rallying behind him the campaign
announced more than two million dollars
has been raised since the debate in
Pennsylvania deserves better
Wednesday Dr Oz held an event with Nikki
Haley the former South Carolina governor
and former president Trump's U.N
Ambassador Natalie Brandt CBS News
Washington
next on politics now we'll take a look
at the week ahead in politics
wait you're never far from Findlay
[Music]
this weekend what to watch We're hearing
from you eight news now well once again
this week is coming week bring you
polling results from Emerson College
we'll cover a wide range of topics and
look at where opinions stand in the
final days of early voting that'll be
Monday here on 8 News Now
also we're looking ahead to election day
of course we are we're going to have
complete coverage for you on Election
night bringing you the most up-to-date
results we'll also be live at some key
watch parties all across Nevada from up
North all the way here down south
that'll do it for us here on politics
now you can stay up to date with all the
political news on eightnewsnow.com we're
back with you here on 8 news now next
Saturday take care
[Music]